martin bernard derrière le volant et
jean michel roberge du côté passager
sont membres de la section éclipse du
spvm les deux policiers sont dépêchés
d'urgence dans un motel de l'est de la
métropole
le compte-rendu effet à leurs
commandants quelque chose
auquel on va dire
c'est la localiser pour qu'on ait gagné
après avoir établi un plan d'action dans
le stationnement
les agents vont rencontrer la préposée à
la réception
les policiers bernard et roberge pensent
avoir localisé l'adolescente au deuxième
étage leurs coéquipières accélère le pas
pour aller les rejoindre souvent les
gens qui sont tapis dans le proxénétisme
sont humains mardi puis le proxénétisme
constitue également une source de
financement pour qu'ils facilitent
actuellement l accès aux armes à feu
cette intervention illustre bien que la
lutte contre le trafic d'armes se fait
sur plusieurs fronts par les policiers
de montréal
la jeune fille de 15 ans est finalement
retrouvée elle est traitée par les
policiers comme une victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle et leur accès à
plusieurs services d'accompagnement
mission accomplie pour le duo de
policiers qui retrouvent leurs
coéquipiers pour la réunion du soir
avant son gain car éclipse ce sont eux
une soixantaine de policiers triés sur
le volet qui interviennent un peu
partout sur l'île de montréal en
fonction des renseignements criminels
qu'ils obtiennent leur spécialité les
crimes organisés
et justement l'intervention qui suit
découle d'une information obtenue par
info crime dans un dossier d'armes à feu
les enquêteurs demandent a procédé à
l'arrestation d'un suspect à son lieu de
travail on évalue que c'est moins risqué
que de se présenter chez lui sachant
qu'ils pourraient être armés à l'arrivée
des policiers les gens qui appellent
info crime les informations sont souvent
sont très bonnes ils sont effectivement
ils sont vérifiées par les enquêteurs
puis ça peut amener à des enquêtes un
peu plus loin aussi d'accord on a besoin
du public ça c'est certain on peut pas
on peut pas être partout le commandant
david paradis a bien hâte de savoir ce
qui va ressortir du forum pour contrer
la violence armée à montréal spvm fait
tout en son pouvoir pour être capable de
de contrer ce phénomène cependant faut
comprendre que l'espm peut pas faire
tout à lui seul donc c'est important
d'avoir également la porte du
communautaire la part des citoyens de
lorient donc je pense que ce forum leur
vont avoir la capacité de rapprocher ces
gens là puis de trouver des solutions
qui sont non seulement applicable au
niveau des services de police mais pour
la société dans son ensemble
quant au prévenu arrêté sur son lieu de
travail il a passé la nuit en
interrogatoire pendant que le spvm munis
d'un mandat de perquisition
investissait son domicile ici pascal
robidas radio canada montréal